you got kids these days 12 13 15 17
years old no one's actually telling them
what to do with their life and I'll tell
you this is not complex stuff you want
to know what you do when you're 13 years
old when you're 15 years old when you're
17 years old work out
yep lift weights to get bigger and
stronger go to jiu jitsu or boxing or
wrestling or Muay Thai so you're not a
fight do that
eat good foods that's what you should do
you shouldn't be drinking drinking and
drugs they're not good for you they
don't help you in any way don't do them
don't spend a bunch of time on video
games or looking at Instagram don't do
that it's not good for you it doesn't
help you try and get smarter you get
smarter by reading a book studying so
you can dominate in life that's what you
do and I don't think there's people
telling 17 year old boys 15 year old
boys 13 year old boys and that's it what
they need to do
so I'm telling them